you sexy [ __ ] way too cuddly he
just [ __ ] cut it you didn't even do a
[ __ ] dragon no [ __ ] slow in not
cut it they made nothing what's
happening you beautiful [ __ ]
welcome to the Church of what's
happening now it's a beautiful day to be
alive [ __ ] Thursday July 16th what
can I tell you you got the world by the
[ __ ] balls that's all I can tell you
right or wrong what did he say it was it
yesterday or today you like you have big
balls and and a neck racism I'm showing
up with a big dick on a neck brace
[ __ ] just in case don't get
confused just case you swallow this
[ __ ] helmet your neck goes back I got
you covered you know I know it's for her
yeah when we [ __ ] think the neck
brace is for some that semantically
unless your name is [ __ ] Chad or
something like that have a [ __ ] Corey
okay you want to go hang out with the
boys you know say that's it it's [ __ ]
him it's July 16 you're sitting around
scratching you look at me scratching his
head oh I got like 10 minutes that was
500 milligram auntie Dolores attaboy Kim
a little corner or the [ __ ] right at
least a hundred I had two big pieces
line of edibles and it's just everything
is the grams everything everything is
always good everything's beautiful check
it out there's a nice little look if you
don't even put in the bag for his auntie
Dolores that's why I love is it
chocolate death bomb you could [ __ ]
throw this on Palestine we're here we're
queer we didn't do yesterday because I
had the fight companion so what's the
[ __ ] difference I'm like I do Park to
podcasts on one day for him kill myself
let's spread them out I hope you enjoy
them a lot people mad at me all the time
but like you didn't talk you all high I
wasn't either when you're in a room with
two [ __ ] got one guy that's a
commentator than one as a fighter
what am I gonna say about a fight woman
I throw my two cents in my stupid to the
end that's where you go back to [ __ ]
trains planes and automobiles and you go
back to Steve Martin what could Steve
Martin had done in the presence of John
Candy well it got squashed
what was he gonna say sure all you could
do it there was a little body language
there's a couple people I caught it when
I came in you like Muhammad Ali you
rope-a-dope a [ __ ] you just throw a
punch when you need to and that's what I
like they're doing that
you have to know when to strike unless
then you become too overbearing so I
don't want people to think I was too
[ __ ] stoned or whatever I don't like
podcasts when you have four people
trying to talk yeah you know there are
there a conjunction type podcast it's
fun for a while
but it's different but I want people to
understand where you stand in that if
you're in a room if you're doing a
basketball podcast and you got Julius
Erving and Magic Johnson on the [ __ ]
table what stupidity are you gonna add
to this yeah what stupidity could I
possibly add to that tape I could add a
little color to it so please it's not
that I was stoned or I was just trying
to be quiet
I would just listen and watch him good
fights and you know what in the time for
just because you were on it but I
watched the frolic i watch the full'
fights with the fight companion that's a
pretty cool way to watch a fight I mean
it's not as in-depth as when Rogen's on
like the the pay-per-view but it was
interesting and when they go on other
tangents yeah you know which is always
good too but uh hey listen man whatever
they make uh anything that helps you
that makes our performance interesting
yeah I knew was going to come down to
that well my friends told me TJ said
that Rogen should start a podcast where
he commentates along with with the UFC
whatever the [ __ ] it is I could see the
UFC going to it because I'm sure there's
a lot of fans who and and just because I
didn't hear them because I had the
podcast up I'm sure the commentators
last night did a great job but when you
have Rogan doing it for so long you know
people who are really loyal to him and I
could see since everything's on the
Internet is heading towards being on the
Internet
[ __ ] it you have three choices of
commentators so if you don't like the
ones we have for free Rogen's on here
for an extra barker or a [ __ ] they
have an i they have another UFC fighter
on there i'm a different one are you
probably three or four teams could be
interesting very intelligent that's uh I
never looked at I had a great time you
know it was the first time I met Brendan
Schwab
hell of a nice guy you know it's amazing
that three of my friends at 26 years old
I've been thinking
Longman he's 26 yes I'll be a baby too
right he said look I'm up I can't tell
this computer was just really weird that
you guys are a 20 species home we got
into the conversation a little bit on
Monday where I was saying that I've been
thinking a lot about that lately
I had nothing zero zero going on at 26
at 26 I was coming out of [ __ ] prison
and the only reason why I had the things
I had was because of the girl I was with
it wasn't because I was I was like I
said I was making 7,000 a month before
him at the prison and having a hard time
paying rent like I would have to hide
from the landlord for [ __ ] three days
because I didn't have the money to pay
rent now he's had to get an advance from
my job that's how [ __ ] up my money
situation was that I was I knew how to
pay rent that I knew how to pay bills
and everything I just didn't want to pay
him you know I didn't want to pay
anything on time I had a good I have a
credit card thing yeah yeah I had a visa
I was like the five hole in it that I
paid you know yeah how old is he he's 31
yeah there's clothes clothes yeah five
years away
31:26 it's it's it's really [ __ ] no
difference but it's amazing and I I that
day that you had to mention it I hadn't
spoken to you buy that went home and I
was like wow Lee and D'Agostino all
these young guys at least they know what
the [ __ ] they wanna do at 26 they're in
the ball game
you know I bumped into somebody at the
airport the other day and we're
bullshitting and he asked me a question
he knows that he didn't he felt really
bad about asking anybody else this you
ready for this what he said to me what
do you when do you realize you're gonna
leave your house did you before you went
to college did you think you were
leaving Boston yeah you knew that
already
I want to go away from college well I
that was maybe one of the mistakes I
made I went to school in Boston it was a
good film so I didn't I didn't
particularly enjoy it I kind of wish I
went to Drexel and filling even though I
wasn't
program just to get out of Boston but
it's a little bit different for me
because I went to film school so the
only places you can go really are New
York and LA so it wasn't really even a
choice there's some people who stay in
Boston but and and and good for them but
they don't really end up doing it how
old were you when you knew you were
gonna leave Boston honestly honestly
when was the first time it crossed your
mind I don't know about leaving Boston I
don't I don't remember that thought but
the joke in my family is that since I
was two I wanted a job an apartment in a
car I have always wanted just to be
older and out I've never and I had a
great childhood but it's just that I've
always wanted to be out and on my own
and it's a it's just luckily love I mean
for me I feel lucky that it was easier
for me there's no other reasonings of
you wanting to leave your hometown I
mean you're a nice kid you never got
arrested you have no warrants no drug
problems I mean what was the reason that
you think there was more out there did
you think that yeah Lord of my hometown
and it's a great place to raise kids but
there's like there's there was nothing
to do there's a blockbuster there's no
father's no like you said you could hop
on a bus to New York to get on a bus I
would have had to go on like 30 or 40
minutes down the road there's nothing
where I grew up so how far are you from
downtown Boston 30 40 minutes it wasn't
that far but it's just there's nothing
if you don't when I turned 16 maybe
that's probably one because when I could
start driving and I could go into the
city and go do stuff that was probably
around the age when I knew I was going
to leave cuz I was in San Jose Lea that
was I went to original Joe's for
breakfast not at the airport how they
mad at that one at San Jose Airport and
some guy came on because I listened to
the podcast I had a couple few
situations this week I had that
situation where he came up to me he was
gonna ask you a personal question I
didn't know what the [ __ ] was like at
8:00 in the morning and he goes when did
you know you wanted to leave your home
and I thought about it for a few days
I'm gonna give you the reasonings I
never thought I was gonna leave New
Jersey in New York I didn't know if
something else existed I had been to
California I've been to Miami in Florida
I've been to Puerto Rico you know I had
been to Michigan for a bitty basketball
tournament I had been to up and down the
East Coast driving back and forth to
Miami as a kid you know I'm talking that
run with family or whatever I never knew
what life was like I'm not gonna lie to
you and tell you I had been out here
with my L : I remember the rocks and the
beach and Dodger Stadium but not enough
to make me want to leave nothing was
enough to make me one with you right
yeah New York I can't imagine well
actually you know but after my mom died
I started looking around all right no no
even then I didn't think so
really one day I was probably Jimmy been
to the first family I moved in after my
mom died and I asked Jimmy up there was
a trucking company named Florida in
Texas that was name of the car that's
really why I didn't know no it was just
better a trucking company Florida Texas
Freight or something like that was
called when I was a kid I still think
they're around Florida Texas the Texas
Florida or something like that and I
said it to him I go mr. bender do you go
work at Texas Florida Florida Texas and
he goes you could do whatever the [ __ ]
you want me goes that's an interesting
question he always good because he
didn't hear the whole question he go say
how we stuck my one of my sons on my
daughter would leave he goes none of
them ever left he goes but it'd be great
just to go look outside the country
because I never thought about know
Florida Texas the talking company but
yeah you could do whatever you want to
do but he had already said that to me
yeah you know right I've been thinking
about it and then that that was the it
there's always a silver lining and I
figured out how 30 years later when I
robbed that jewelry store when I was a
kid and the cops are looking for me I
had to go to Sarasota Florida for four
weeks yeah and that's it snowing without
once you know you could live without
something you don't know you never know
you never know like before I went to
prison I'm like ah no refunds
I'm gonna make it and after the third
night of no reefer that's it I adjusted
there was no sense in crying there was
no sense of yelling or talking about it
nothing can help we grow through the
[ __ ] prison walls so what the [ __ ]
you don't saying once you realize you
can live without something it's like
people always break up after somebody
takes a vacation or something because
once they realize I never [ __ ] miss
you I didn't really [ __ ] think about
you in fact I was happy you weren't
around that makes sense you know yeah
it's very happy that you weren't around
once people realize that they could do
without something it's crazy and I'll
tell you what I love Matt Berger I love
where I'm from I love him enjoy the
people I grew up if I knew something
that always killed me there's something
that killed me about people there's two
things I can't tolerate white trash I
can't tolerate them I thought the
mindset of white trash they grow up they
get a job and they play the hand down
they don't even play the hand out you
know I was surrounded by white trash in
North Bergen good people you know I'm
not saying nothing bad about some good
god-fearing Americans you know that's
not it but I always feather their dreams
were too small in fact I don't think
they had [ __ ] dreams I see that more
now that I'm out here I didn't see it
when you see what I'm sayin T and that
bothered the [ __ ] out of me I call white
trash the people a person who doesn't
have a dream somebody who comes up to me
and says guess what the Allman Brothers
are in Atlantic City you know we're
gonna party out and I look at them and I
see how excited they get that brings
pain to my heart yeah it brings that
much pain to my heart you know that that
little like the Allman Brothers aren't
even together no more like that I think
they retire but not even like the
original band right you know it's like
you were telling me before about Pink
Floyd like 18 people have hit me up
already and so you excited about Pink
Floyd gonna tell the truth
not at all I haven't even [ __ ] thought
about it I don't give a [ __ ] you know I
don't give a [ __ ] of they put a new
album i'll and i will i buy it who the
[ __ ] knows i might put it on but i don't
want to see that stuff it's like you
were saying to me do you want to go see
Aerosmith the slash at the Coliseum or
are you [ __ ] crazy
are you [ __ ] crazy you know I saw
Aerosmith
whenever smoked was Aerosmith and they
were never even ever smith because
anybody who knows when you went to see
harassment went the heroin they were
horrendously bad hate to see this band
was a superpower and and they were
horrendously bad because of the drugs
and I don't know how they are now people
you know nobody's gonna pay fifty five
dollars for a ticket the concert sucked
yeah do you know I'm saying it's against
their whole thing and I got to pay a
hundred all especially now I'm conscious
three alarms and I'm gonna come back and
go oh man that sucked
nothing gonna come back but back to the
white trash thing I always felt they had
no dreams like even in high school you'd
say what's going on northing then I
can't wait for my father to get me this
job in this warehouse I'm gonna get $18
an hour and that was it yeah they don't
go on vacation they never leave New
Jersey they wouldn't even dream a
[ __ ] leaving New Jersey a little core
that they belong to oh they get excited
about the weirdest [ __ ] things and my
hometown North Bergen there's a you know
at this point now there's maybe four
[ __ ] bars that these young kids could
go you know but guess a [ __ ] you're ten
minutes away from the greatest city in
the world I mean that's the advantage of
being from North Bergen New Jersey but
you get people from North Bergen on
frying out a little [ __ ] moose club
and this is like a bunch of people at
all built like I am though it was big as
I am and they go
and then they talking about highschool
football and they're stuck in that time
warp yeah like that's the white trash
I'm talking about this stuck in this
[ __ ] time warp of their mind that
there's no dreaming there's no nothing
they just call exist with life that
works for a lot of people that wasn't
gonna work for me
are you jealous at all cuz I have some I
would I never had a huge I had a couple
friends in high school but not all your
group of like six or seven I'll go on
Facebook now and I'll see that they're
still hanging out and then at parties
and I hated all of them Liz I don't want
to be there but like maybe ten percent
amis jealous that they still like hang
out and most of me thinks it's stupid
but part of me is like oh my god that'd
be nice to stall friends from the high
school but I don't I talked to one kid
from high school that's it
I'm very lonely mm-hmm but I'm very
lonely because I want to be I'm very
lonely at times because I want to be do
you follow me
yeah in my mind those kids I grew up
with that was the best that got from me
that was the best it would ever be for
me and I never tried to duplicate that
even hanging out with comedians if I
hung out with for comedians
but top-notch comedians in the country
they wouldn't give me as much humor as I
did when I grew up with those guys and I
know there's going in right because
they're not trying they worked on timing
everything was based on timing it was
life they reacted to life and they were
very funny about doing it I can't take
back half those things now I'm not
glamorizing that life of living in the
past but those type of friends I grew up
with and look that'll never happen yet
again I love you and you're a good kid
I just know that it was a different
situation and it required a different
type of friendship you know the cops are
never gonna come knocking on your door
go is Joey and you don't giggle in their
face and get the [ __ ] out of my face the
slam the door as
gonna happen in this lifetime yeah three
people and I'm knocking it don't say
where's your buddy Joey Diaz he robbed
me you know and you're gonna go I
haven't seen them in two weeks [ __ ] you
if we don't have our money we're gonna
beat the [ __ ] out of you two in three
days that takes a certain type of friend
somebody would say [ __ ] you I'll tell
you where he is right now yeah
these [ __ ] like you said what
you better [ __ ] choose your words
[ __ ] them wisely I'm gonna choose your
[ __ ] words wisely you're not gonna do
[ __ ] to me do you know it was different
it was a different time yeah but I'm
very lonely you know in that aspect
because I could go to Hollywood improv
and goof around with a bunch of people
then at the end of the week who gives a
[ __ ] right you know I could go to Comedy
Store it again huh oh my god funny joke
is a [ __ ] when I get my car you talk
about how I do blow and now you know
whatever the [ __ ] my [ __ ] you might give
yourself for why not you're achieving
your goals on why not you're doing what
the [ __ ] you doing so it was just really
weird I just he asked me what I found
out and I knew a year after my mother
died I was getting the [ __ ] out of there
and it wasn't because I hated the people
or you know like I said white trash to
me of people that you see him and you
know you gonna see him in 30 years and
nothing changed and they're happy
they're happy about it I always wanted
more yeah I always wanted a challenge
every day you know I want to get
challenged every day when I wake up in
the morning I want a different type of
day you know people hit me up all the
time they hit us up all the time hey man
we have a song for the church guess what
take your [ __ ] song and shove it up
your [ __ ] ass only your [ __ ] song
I'm gonna tell you why because if you
only think about me I can't do the same
[ __ ] twice every day so why would I want
to hear your [ __ ] song every [ __ ]
day I appreciate that you took the time
and write in it and I love you to death
but push your [ __ ] magic elsewhere
[ __ ] you know last night some dude
was trying to get me to play Warren
Zevon did you see that conversation no
he's only better yeah can you play my
buddy shot himself this week
can you play Warren Zevon I haven't
listened to the first three [ __ ]
words of this song I got to pay
something I would have shot myself too I
would have shot myself and the [ __ ]
hell if I had to listen tonight who's
the other one you hate at the Bailey she
said if you party I [ __ ] hate that
dude that's to do that every party you
go to someone who sings yeah oh no no no
let's put on I forget what the [ __ ] it
was like he's taking a [ __ ] at a time
he's America's Sweetheart they all love
them you know the Gentile nation you
know anybody who wears the [ __ ] the
Hat with Sinatra to the side they all
[ __ ] yeah that guy you know [ __ ] you
I'll put for anything on compares to
that [ __ ] every day that guy that sounds
like he's taking a [ __ ] Rick Rehn was
like sir oh really we have Rick Ramos
needs to try to turn me out them I heard
him one then I call real Rick you're not
[ __ ] serious you're not [ __ ]
serious are you the [ __ ] is that guy's
name
it's someone tweet at me if you remember
I forget what the [ __ ] is that guy's
name I can't stand that [ __ ] yeah my
buddy died can you play this song I
never get the [ __ ] that no wonder he
died I [ __ ] die too
he's like well if you can't play that
song you could play this I'm gonna play
that [ __ ] song
eat it that sound wait Tom Waits or
Jesus Christ
thank you injections that is the [ __ ]
worse that [ __ ] is a [ __ ] worst garbage
I have ever had listened to in my life
that is [ __ ] worse at least that
white trash not Burgundy listen to at
least the people I grew up with listen
to real [ __ ] music you weren't
allowed to fake the funk but you were
not allowed to fake the funk at all come
up with like to be queued front of some
girl you know failing yeah oh no you
know put on Springsteen like you never
heard that [ __ ] for somebody would stab
you in the [ __ ] neck there's a
Sabbath house [ __ ] get your [ __ ]
together oh my god but it was
it's just weird like that to see those
type of people that you just knew that
could and I love them I'm not saying
nothing bad about them that was their
prerogative prerogative but they're
gonna settle and I just didn't want to
settle me you know yeah was that your
mindset behind leaving or was your
mindset yeah I just wanted I don't it
probably was but not maybe I maybe I'm
not smart enough to realize it yet it's
still it's still only a few years ago um
it moved for wait I know and but I
always thought I'll tell you this I
always thought it'd be New York even
after I was out here for a few months
interning and I went back I thought I'd
be in New York I'm gonna had a job in LA
and I just I came out and now it's now
it's home but I always thought it would
be New York you know and I always hated
that also that of a mind that of a
small-minded thing about the guy you
know like the guy like a mayor like the
mayor of not Bergen he's a [ __ ] putz
you know I know him when he was a kind
of system principal at Lincoln School
the guy's a [ __ ] putz but if you go
to North Bergen on a guy walks in alone
people I call I never had respect for
that mindset either yeah [ __ ] that
[ __ ] that [ __ ] puts his little
pants on one leg at a time that's why I
can never be like I saw Julius Erving I
saw Richard Gere when I was a kid I
didn't give a [ __ ] you know I would go
up to him to shake down like I didn't
say nothing Richard Gere at a club and
Julius Erving was my [ __ ] Idol pretty
much growing up but I would never
my mom always instilled this thing on me
like a [ __ ] them they put their pants on
one leg at a time - yeah you know they
they maybe whatever there may be
celebrities where the [ __ ] they call
himself but they put their pants on one
leg at a time so I came and my home was
like when you have a job and let's say
the guy's name is Jim and you're the
assistant editor you know Jim always
shows up two hours that's the eight
o'clock shift he always shows up in a
bad mood like he's just genius and he's
always got something on his mind
yeah and you're sitting there waiting
for me to say something to see what kind
of Moody's and before you react I always
hated that [ __ ] mentality
yeah I don't have that [ __ ] around me it
was a [ __ ] what this guy thinks or what
movies in you know my wife I love my
wife to death but she's the nicest
person in the [ __ ] world like when
she asked me how is the gym today I want
to choke her like how could the [ __ ]
gym beat we think they were doing down
there giving out hors d'oeuvres it's a
[ __ ] lie my wife was people always
said how was your flight
my flight was shitty it was like every
other [ __ ] flight you're on you get
on there you can't wait for it to
[ __ ] end go for the plane the [ __ ]
hit every time you're on the plane you
pray that the plane don't [ __ ] crash
that somebody don't smell like [ __ ] that
somebody doesn't open up [ __ ] hummus
those are the five prayers you have when
I got on a [ __ ] plane that's the
first damn thing have a [ __ ] as a plane
ride you know my wife I love my wife and
my wife doesn't ask me however how is
your plane ride coming in all just
spectacular you gotta see the rest of
the people in the back stretch down
scratching their nuts to [ __ ] sit in
the back like sardines how the [ __ ] you
think my plane ticket was you [ __ ] let
it play $25 for luggage the fat [ __ ]
next to me was fart and he was drooling
on my shirt
you know stop stop trying to give a [ __ ]
so month how was the gym it was great my
hands smell like ass yeah you put him on
the [ __ ] political machine some rats
- I spray the [ __ ] stuff on my hands
really after this yeah because after why
they have paper yeah they have
disinfectant spray and then they have
like easy wipes I take the easy wipes I
easy why I learned about them at Terry
I'm like I'm on my [ __ ] hands when I
jerk off or wipe my ass
that's all I put us elliptical hand in
my [ __ ] next you know my [ __ ]
[ __ ] moving back and forth I'm trying
to sit there with the elliptical German
[ __ ] people put their hands on that
[ __ ] 24-hour Fitness yeah how many
[ __ ] people you think actually wash
their hands not actually take a [ __ ] or
they [ __ ] pop take that dick and piss
I don't mind if a woman scratches a
[ __ ] or shakes my hand I don't mind
that sure you can shake president you
could leave a [ __ ] pubic hair and a
crab in my [ __ ] ass [ __ ] but these
dudes you got to assume so when I get
off that lip tickle I spray my hands I
spray my [ __ ] hands I go over to the
elliptical
spray that [ __ ] I wipe it down nice my
[ __ ] : I get my fingernails nice
everything cuz I shower at home do you
shower at the gym uh depends where I go
if I go to the why just walk home yeah I
just walk home why am I gonna [ __ ]
take a shower there with a bunch of men
in cold water and no towels and [ __ ]
yeah yeah look at people's dicks like I
look at my dick I don't want to see that
[ __ ] if I go to jujitsu I just shot cuz
I have my knee brace so I take off my
pants push off the knee brace so I just
drive off switch t-shirts get my clown
shoe home and wash my ass when I get out
of a [ __ ] car
yeah that's the first thing somebody
[ __ ] up having to me yesterday what
happened and it's funny that you brought
up high school so I've been working out
and I were I was set little goals for
myself each day to either move the
resistance up or to get to a different
distance or different calorie so
yesterday I had a goal for 800 calories
and I felt great when uh when I was
doing it I felt really pumped up but my
water was hot and I started really drink
much of it was on the elliptical and I
liked chugged it when I got off because
I was dying and when I sat down in the
locker room I was sure I was gonna puke
well I had to stash that down for like
ten minutes and people were staring at
me because it's kind of busy and I was
just doing that breathing or like please
don't puke and I thought about it and
the only this was the first time I was
gonna puke from working out well I I
joined freshman football in high school
I never did Pop Warner but I was trying
to like do some stuff like that and I
hated it so much that one day I
pretended to puke cuz I I saw something
like he said puked and Liebig out of
practice like [ __ ] if I puke I can get
out of practice so I pretended to one
day but yesterday I was sitting on the
bench at the 24 hour fitness
sure I was gonna puke and I I didn't the
only reason I didn't get up to go to the
toilet was cuz I I thought if I stood up
it was gonna happen but I was able to
calm myself down but it's just it's uh
it's funny like oh like all I could
think about on that bench was me going
into the to the leaves and pretending I
was puking in freshman football and now
you really will go [ __ ] oh it was
terrible
800 calories
calories yeah I've moved up I started
out at I think 2 1 or 4 1 on the
resistance in height and now I was at 7
for yesterday
so you bad [ __ ] a day now you'd
be [ __ ] writing a bicycle with that
do with the one nut any [ __ ] Dana
you'll be calling me up from some
Mountain gonna guess who I'm with right
now I'm about to take a turn over here
it's [ __ ] some pass I'm proud of you
looking trying yeah twenty pounds a day
and you like the 24-hour fitness I'm
beginning to I feel guilty when I don't
go but I'm not at the point yet where I
am I'm enjoying it but I tell you what's
helped me and it's probably I would
probably go harder if I wasn't doing it
but I do as much or keep going every day
I bring my iPad and I watch movies now
because I saw another lady doing I
started lady with a DVD player and I was
watching 300 yesterday I was getting
really pumped up and it makes the time
go by so much quicker for me forget
what's going on I'm gonna music guy how
a music guy
get lost in it cuz I can't I get lost
even with music I'm just like I just if
mom I try to switch up the music you
know like I always bring a different
album and my goal is like hit the bag to
the side of an album out any minute so
like the I dad they're like seven songs
that were good in a row like there was
three stone songs and like two Sabbath
songs along like Pat Benatar song with
some [ __ ] like you don't solve set goals
that way yeah do what I know while I was
thirty something minutes you know listen
man I don't want anybody to think that
when I tell him I like working out I
[ __ ] hate it yeah I [ __ ] hate it
too that's why I like getting it over
with yeah you know I like getting it the
[ __ ] off with yesterday I go did you did
too like this my buddy does these drills
at his house and I had nothing going on
so I wanna go over there I didn't break
much of a sweat but today I'm really
[ __ ] sore like I'm stepping and you
got a step and stretch your leg and fall
back and then do this [ __ ] pendulum
kick and
it's pretty interesting that I know I
have to do something every day I know I
like I like to stretch also yeah did you
stretch every time because I hadn't been
stretching I'll tell you when my
Achilles tendon has started to like
tighten up some people said people send
some stretchy to do yeah you have to
stretch out stretching cold
they say mm-hmm it's bad for your
muscles I don't have to stretch cold
okay so a lot of times what I'll do is
when I get out there I'll just loosen
the joint my elbows my shoulder joints
my hips my knees my ankles I'll loosen
them a little bit right and let's say I
just shadow box just shadow box twisting
whatever once you break that sweat
you're warmed up okay so that I do this
is how I categorize everybody else has
their own system people here and then
you know that's after a 10-minute warmup
then I do a little light stretching boom
boom boom and then let's say I'm gonna
hit the bag I attack the bag why do hip
escapes why do a couple exercises that
I'm gonna do in jiu-jitsu to really
break that sweat going you know and then
I go for it then you go then after you
workout I to was not warming up was not
stretching after workout and I'll tell
you what it saves you a little soreness
hmm you don't get a sore and again I die
stretch everything my calves my thighs
my hamstrings my glutes my back is very
important I do a bunch of yoga stretches
I do uh you know I this last week um is
very interesting because like I said uh
I like yoga I like you Jitsu I like
everything about you just so I'm a bit
big for it and my movement is a little
slow
I never wrestled in high school but that
doesn't stop me I have different things
like my breathing in jiu-jitsu is
horrifying
you know I've quit smoking the dope I've
tried to and I know it's the weight you
know three hundred pounds is a lot of
weight to move around so I understand
from
to lose some weight but the confidence
thing for me in jujitsu is my breathing
that after two minutes if I'm on bottom
and I do a couple hip escapes i gotta
tap out right if I if I get on top of
you and I go to submit you I gotta stop
because I'm not breathing if you rolled
your shoulder and it goes into my solar
plex I can't breathe you know well I'm
sure if you recorded herself when he
first started cuz you've been doing it
for almost a year and a half yeah
I'm sure you're a lot better at it the
breathing has gotten a lot better but
it's not to where I thought it would be
so that's why I'm doing this dieting I'm
doing a lot more cardio now and you know
like I went through a doctor the other
day I went to a specialized doctor it
was a friend of a friends and he told me
that my hips were sideways that's why I
was having knee problems he was full of
a chiropractor Plus okay - 150 [ __ ]
big you know and it's hysterical I don't
know how people live their lives without
insurance oh I have to get insurance now
cuz I'm gonna turn 26 I can't be my
parents anymore so that's it it's over
for you it's [ __ ] expensive how much
made them over 200 a month minimum and
it's probably gonna be more than that
that's 2,400 a year for nothing yeah for
nothing that's not no dental no vision
yeah that's like a halal deductible off
at the doctor's office is something like
that and let me tell you something I
don't want you to suck I don't want you
to be a [ __ ] at 26 I wasn't even
thinking about [ __ ] light shines oh
yeah at 26 I didn't think about
insurance or doctors or anything
listen it's it's [ __ ] amazing
how expensive is like I thought this guy
was gonna charge me 65 bucks I didn't
have enough money in my ATM card I had
to put on my Visa card my wife don't
even [ __ ] know yet
$250 my wrist though hurts
he said he adjusted my neck and some
[ __ ] in my brain which is funny because
that night I had I had an experience
happening in my sleep that has not
to me heaven before what happened I once
heard a doctor Tuesday and I have
acupuncture I had a meeting in Hollywood
I couldn't made you Jitsu in the daytime
I didn't make it back over the hill to
125 and they canceled my two o'clock so
I was [ __ ] pissed so I just went home
and waited till my 3:30 and I had a 3:30
with him either
my 3:30 was at this [ __ ] doctor okay
so I get over time basically went for
this doctor for pain my wrist pain I
didn't tell about my name my knee is on
fire again not as bad as it was before
they shot so I've been taking it easy
lately I've been trying to work out
every other day like usually you work
out two days or on and two days off a
two on one off two one and too often one
on you know I'm just doing every up
because it's too much I could feel after
the second day that my knee hurts right
so this is just common sense I just wish
he gave me this advice rob will do by
you know what [ __ ] we called it a mile
about what happened when he was sleeping
so uh I went to his doctor and he
adjusted all this [ __ ] and I got up in
the middle of night my wife was passed
out I got my mom like the beat and when
I got back and bet I put my mask on I
laid down and he was like I was getting
too much it oh I get was getting too
much in all of a sudden I started
feeling weird like it was too much and
I'm grasping for air and I'm grasping
for air and it was too much I had to get
up and take my mask off and walk around
like I was getting this reversed anxiety
oh [ __ ] you know so I know the guy
affected me some way another he must
have touched something but he did tell
me some pretty interesting things he
told me to tape my mouth at night when I
slept and I would lose five pounds I'm
on tape your mouth taped my mouth I just
breathe through my nose cuz I breathe
through my mouth yeah so he goes your
oxygen is completely different from your
nose and your mouth through your mouth
you pick up a lot of dirt and everything
it's dragging to you all
we didn't know was we ever felt that he
was breaking it down and he said if he
wanted me to like my Carly on fire in
fact you gotta put a program on my phone
and an app to get my heart rate okay
because he goes whatever your heart rate
is I want you to touch it when you just
wake up touch it whatever your heart
rate there's only 30 steps like you
going up steps mm-hmm and then stop
I don't you do it again so it goes right
back for the original heart rate I don't
care what you need to do anything goes
do thirty thousand to five five to ten
times and he goes your cardio or elevate
you know and I also been doing rectifier
lately some but that it's con Delaney
yoga now and my man Denny is a certified
yoga instructor I worked with him this
weekend whole bit and San Jose San Jose
it was great because I did that type of
[ __ ] you know that's cool
listen man I like all that nerd [ __ ] and
I don't like fear I hate fear in my life
you know a lot of times I'm a little
jujitsu because I'm like I don't wanna
get stuck up today I'm not in the mood
to not be able to breathe there's a
period in my jujitsu it could be what
I'm rolling sometimes it could be what
I'm doing a hip escape or it could be
when I'm doing a drill the oxygen
disappeared and I have this the sweat
just totals old my body it's the
weirdest [ __ ] thing it just comes
over me
this little [ __ ] skunk sweat and I
feel it from my feet all the way to the
top of my head it's just a light layer
of sweat that coats my body just happen
every time every time that I run out of
oxygen I think I'm gonna [ __ ] die I
don't know but this do you run out of
oxygen every time you every time I have
one at some point in my workout some
point with the kettlebells I'll get that
little jaunt to me one my hold on one
second my heart's going fast I gotta get
my [ __ ] brains to me and I and I do
make my thing I had no I I'm not a
doctor but has anyone ever said you
should get on some anxiety medicine or
do you not want to like has that ever
been ever thought about it about ten
years ago going
anxiety medicine I was doing heavy-duty
cocaine and it wasn't working I would do
pills at the end of my cocaine trip at
3:00 in the morning 4:00 in the morning
and I don't know I don't know it wasn't
I went to anxiety for me was taken care
of by dr. Amy you know well it helps
yeah that's why I basically went to dr.
Amy for a long time was the anxiety and
I noticed the difference like a month
after I someone to see dr. Amy anxiety
is caused now guys I know you people
gonna hate me on Twitter and [ __ ]
send me messages this is my feeling
anxiety is like a lack of confidence in
the mind mm-hmm like it's like a brain
fart for me it was like there was
something else that was bothering me and
for me focusing on it so much it gave me
this anxiety that's how I felt about it
I could be wrong guys I think that's
what it is for most people I could be
wrong this is how it felt like for me
and this is how it felt like for me
after the anxiety had been taken away it
felt like I had my mind had bumped into
a problem that it couldn't solve and
because of that I can't breathe
my my tolerance goes up on a piano like
if something happens right away I go
that place is that you know I know
matter what happens and and the number
one trigger of that was when I lost my
breath like there's mornings I would
just get to a [ __ ] radio interview
and I would walk up the stairs real fast
and like after the top of the stairs
like the people be talking to me I go
like hold on one second I gotta catch my
[ __ ] bearings to me it makes sense
cuz I mean your body must think you're
dying my anxiety would go up which would
make me feel like I was gonna pass out
yeah so I think the acupuncture has
helped my anxiety a lot a lot plus going
to the gym
you know like I said to you going to the
gym isn't about listen to music and it's
not about watch that an iPad it's really
about breaking down something mm-hmm you
know a lot of times when you ask me a
questions what do I say to you I paint a
few days yeah let me work out a couple
times let me work I'm not telling you
that I'm gonna walk into that workout
and from the time I'm doing kettlebells
I'm thinking about Leigh's question it's
gonna pop up in my mind it's it's uh
it's on a revolving you know you have
your ipod what is that called shuffle
shuffle yeah it's on shuffle so not only
am I thinking about mercy Noah you're
thinking about my knee my thinking about
what jokes I'm gonna say no your mom was
thinking I'm what songs are not playing
the podcast boom I also have the thought
that [ __ ] we asked me you know what
are we gonna do we want to do this
podcast you following me that's what it
all comes up that's why I like to work
out that's why I like to walk that's why
you have to meditate you know you can
just sit you know meditation isn't what
people tell you meditation all the time
it's like well you have to go to a dark
corner and light a candle on incense and
you got to take your shoes off and put
your hands like this and let the
shavasana into you and the [ __ ]
spirit of death no meditation is what
takes you away for 20 minutes yeah do I
want you to sit in a [ __ ] long ago
okay yeah if you want to be part of the
Pepsi generation meditation is those
twenty two minutes at the gym that you
sit there after the workouts over and
you say the quality drinking that water
and your leg is up and you're sweating
and something comes into your body
you've got this you've got the sense of
accomplishment from finishing your
workout and now you're going to your
next hurdle and that's
when you're sitting in that corner I
throw a workout and you're putting your
socks on you have when you take your
socks off and you about to take a shower
but something makes you pop your head up
yeah you think about something I thought
you centered your head
yeah that's meditation that's that's
really half the reason not half a
quarter Louise I'm excited about going
to Vegas is because I know I get to
drive
and then you've got hours for some
people it could just be you know what I
write this joke on the way the gig I'm
gonna be in a call for four hours anyway
and it's funny because you say that to
yourself today
it's Thursday afternoon you're planning
on leaving tomorrow yeah okay so the
first time you get in your car right and
you're driving what are you thinking
about the traffic this [ __ ] jerk-off
look at this guy cut me off you know
whatever thought I put enough money and
I leave enough cat food for the cat you
think of all the exterior things you
think of you can't believe they're still
letting [ __ ] kids in from Mexico you
know you're thinking of all these things
like you haven't heard about the kids
this week from Mexico that's it really
that's it they shine the light on it now
they took the light off and now buses
are tripled Jesus now the buses of
triples because if these people are law
there's going to be like the Marielle
thing all over again
this is Marielle Cuba night oh really
nine yeah this is Mario Cuban they're
gonna send you kids but in between those
kids you don't have [ __ ] and convicts
and drug smugglers so we might get sixty
thousand kids or whatever the [ __ ]
but twenty thousand those kids okay you
know forty thousand two fucked-up little
[ __ ] that shoot spitballs and
[ __ ] you know [ __ ] take a
skateboard and go up hill so are we
talking about driving meditation when
you're driving so after the first hour
goes away Paula Joey the podcast what
happens that for the first I want to
have your body maintains you breathe
your breathing his [ __ ] level because
you're not doing jumping jacks
same thing of meditation yeah meditation
is all you controlling your breathing I
did that meditation for a while my dad
was really into it yeah when took
classes you know every day you know
things pop up in here
and you don't know what they are and
some people refer to your meditation
exercise or at the end of the day what
are we talking about an hour of your
time where you dedicate it to you
has nothing to do it life or you're
[ __ ] stupid [ __ ] job or your
stupid [ __ ] wife or your stupid
[ __ ] kid
it's an hour a day that you take care of
yourself that the phone doesn't exist
it's just you in the universe and your
[ __ ] shorts you know I can't re and I
re wasn't calling today okay he wasn't
he just came from Montreal how he's
doing uh this is not happening this is
not happening which i think is a great
idea the reason why I like that this is
not happening so much is because it
makes me sit down and write something
listen there's a difference between
telling a story and telling a great
story
and telling a great story is you want
the person to smell it if you want to be
a good storyteller remember what I'm
[ __ ] telling you I gotta have least
smell it he's I gotta take him there I
gotta bring him there for ten seconds
ten seconds I did my job just as long as
one part of that story really brings you
there brings you there takes you there
you know so the topics for this this is
not happening our romance friendship
childhood and danger romance ain't one
of my favorite [ __ ] topics mm-hmm I
don't get it I'm not a handsome guy so I
never really got romance too much
dangers my middle [ __ ] name childhood
I told too many [ __ ] stories about my
childhood and and friendship I know a
little bit about this because it was
introduced to me from a different
[ __ ] angle friendship so I picked
friendship you know but it's funny how
Ari and I had been talking on the phone
three times a day for the last ten days
and yesterday when we had the meeting
with Comedy Central we had like uh what
do you call those one it would be that's
on the phone
a confidence quo uh-huh I said to calm
me I said to Comedy Central in front of
Hari
they'll kindly Central by the way our
and I have been talking every day for
the last ten days and they were like
really oh my god that's great I know
we're really going over this I go
because I'm his friend and I'm fine I
have to be better than everybody else
yeah after I'm saying and even beyond
twice before right before I have to be
better everybody else and it's so fine
when you write these so the difference
with this one is it's going to be on TV
yeah so they're not you're gonna have to
we're gonna have to you have to take me
somewhere you have the blondie stuff
yeah you have to take me somewhere doing
the story and then when I said to calmly
essentially gonna put a commercial on to
show us how it's gonna look
ah we can rearrange the story to make it
work with who makes away for the
commercial break you know I'm so funny
that this writing has made me write
other material like I was stuck right
material and ever since I've been
writing this project it's so weird how I
turn this story around and I told what
it was three weeks ago and what it is
now I got this [ __ ] itch on my back I
swear to god I'm a like this [ __ ]
t-shirt on five so [ __ ] itchy
you want some more brownie see you and I
I told you I feel it coming but what's
it coming it's alright what's coming you
looking handsome what's coming as a
turkey sandwich at Subway would you stop
with that [ __ ] turkey [ __ ] do you
think I know but it's [ __ ] what else
I'm gonna get right now not Turkey they
gotta have something else about you
writing lists or [ __ ] sorry
isn't that after all these years of
comic I get more from I used to sit
there to write a joke and nothing would
happen now I sit there and write this
story for Harvey and I write for jokes
because there's no waste of time
yeah are you with me so I used to sit
there before like with a pen in my mouth
and say okay I gotta write a joke about
me I love when he puts hair gel on right
now I don't do that no more
I actually yeah [ __ ] story
what's my hose pages probably a [ __ ]
towel marker I'm gonna call you this
one's from Cleveland Ohio I got one why
I tell him markers calling you so fun I
don't know how did they get this number
I think it's websites or the stores when
even the stores make you give it to them
every morning at 7 o'clock I get
something from some weird state
Wisconsin that [ __ ] pisses me off
dresses change my number we were talking
about three good things we forgot what
the [ __ ] they're supposed to conduct the
functors day morning July 16th except
you are there [ __ ] get up wash
your [ __ ] deodorize it's gonna be a
warm one today it's humid out there
Weezer Louie you want the rest is cloudy
yes what time
I'm much because it's Rickon and Steve
who have no [ __ ] podcast we've worked
until 6:00 a.m. he texted me right as I
got here what was he doing he's doing
something for the ESPYs or something
they had them little 6 a.m. with the
ESPYs last night yes when there was a
party afterward must be yeah yeah they
had him at the after-party shaking hands
oh [ __ ] jumping up and down Steve Simone
is a [ __ ] hustler [ __ ] yeah
you know it's amazing how people you
know you think that we're out here
there's a glamorous life this [ __ ] like
that
it wouldn't be so it would be so [ __ ]
clan which what were we doing up at 4:45
I'm saying it's the same [ __ ]
glamorous we do it because we love doing
it but it's amazing how some people
[ __ ] work and some people don't work
League
we steal speed doesn't give a [ __ ] that
kid moves around I mean he goes to San
Diego how I go to the Hollywood yeah hey
this talks about San Diego like it's
nothing like I'm going to San Diego
again he's in La Jolla every other
[ __ ] weekend I don't know how the
[ __ ] he does it yeah
he's just I know neck that guy for a
long time and he's one of those
sweethearts of Carly when they do that
special the sweethearts that comes
sweethearts of comedy do I have him on
and on top of that he just you know he
was doing security is it guy that's a
great comedian he just taped the CD and
it never ends with him you know and
that's how you have to be like people
think like oh once I do this I'll never
do this again you do it needs to be done
we don't leave you scratching hazel oh
are you starting to get hot yeah I could
tell y'all giggling your heads already
cut I caught you you were sitting there
dreaming like a pizza
jack-in-the-box or tuna fish sandwiches
some [ __ ] but it's amazing that I I hope
you people pay attention at home that
this is not just you know Steve didn't
have to be here at 6:00 in the morning
Monday I could just have him call it a
quarter seven I asked him to call and he
goes no I'm coming in that's a work
ethic and that's the work ethic that you
don't see a while out here that people
complain I bumped into somebody I'm
[ __ ] Sunday Sunday brother somebody
routes a comic and he asked me two
questions he was very nice and then he
went on a tangent how he doesn't have
anything that nobody calls him for
anything and I said can I ask you a
personal question
when was the last time I saw you it was
all about four years what have you been
doing you know it's amazing how people
don't want to do anything but they want
the phone to ring yeah I want to do
anything but they want the
on terrain if you want your phone to
ring you got to put yourself out there
you know I'm a
I hate when comics think that all they
have to do is go to the Improv and get a
cocktail and hang out and that's what
they need to do no you need to listen I
don't care you go to the shittiest hope
of my table there it's still an open mic
you're still around your peers you're
still gonna be around eight to ten
people that are in the same boat as you
one of those 10 people has a comedy show
somewhere they do because they're trying
to strive that person's gonna call you
but the only way for him to call you is
guess what if he [ __ ] knows about you
yeah if he doesn't know about you I
can't call you I haven't seen this kid
since he was for a TV show I go didn't
you get a job after they goes no they
never call me back after that whatever
and I'm like you got onstage because not
really nobody gives me spots do you go
down it not really cuz nobody gives me
spots don't what do you do
I forgot you you forget about somebody
all the time you ever get mad at
yourself and you get back on the gun you
go I'm mad at myself
I remember the dumbest [ __ ] things
but I forgot that guy was yeah and I
forgot about him because out of sight
out of [ __ ] mind it's like anything
else man if I don't [ __ ] see you how
we gonna call you exactly so it's
amazing the mindset that people have no
way I mean while spew Simone is working
the ESPYs til 6:00 in the [ __ ]
morning you know yes I mean it's uh it's
gonna it's nice to see with him
especially because we when we started
the podcast he like I don't know he he
he was telling me Barlow stuff on like
you would feel bad but now he's happy
and he's doing well now we have the CD
coming out if he couldn't complain he
wouldn't be [ __ ] happy
if you don't Steve Simone if he wouldn't
complain he wouldn't be [ __ ] happy so
yeah you have it that that's the problem
he's one of those guys
he's like my mother you know he [ __ ]
that year if he's busy and he'll [ __ ]
it yeah if he's if he's not [ __ ] busy
yeah but he'll [ __ ] it you more
he's not busy because he's not lazy
[ __ ] God you know yeah and that's
what you gotta respect idea you know all
these people you eat I I get requests
from people this morning I woke up four
messages on Facebook every one of them
was either a podcast appearance or or a
gig or something like that and the
podcast guys are guys though looking for
a quick hit my cache is Morris caches
Morris as the young kid yeah that kid
works harder than most adults I know
that's why I'll do whatever them I need
to do for caches because he doesn't give
a [ __ ] cassius Morris is always
interviewing somebody he's always at a
concert he's always texting he's always
[ __ ] facebooking you know he's got a
dream you know in 20 years caches Morris
is gonna be [ __ ] deadly right he's at
least 13 15 summarizes he's a few years
from coming out here but yeah he's gonna
be here soon was gonna go to college
right well yeah probably unless he go
somewhere the [ __ ] house I just wish
he does well I know he's gonna do well
he's got that work I think at a young
[ __ ] age gonna do great
who saw the [ __ ] commercial Gabriel
aces that was cool yeah moon bling fit
what wouldn't Wayne fit are you gonna
take the family go see that movie what
movie
Oh Gabriel Iglesias I'm so high I'm so I
think you've been Felipe Esparza
commercial yeah I said you have you seen
Felipe sponsors commercial yeah on what
can somebody please [ __ ] tell me what
on TV no no because it's [ __ ] in LA
they played Spanish commercials every
once in a while and then I think he
tweeted it it's on you bomb so high that
you said Felipe no I seen the commercial
for Gabe oh yeah that was awesome if you
guys listen to the show and support the
show you know I break your balls about
honor and I break your balls about
nature's box I break your balls about
now
you know I don't ask a lot of you guys
but do me a favor man if you get a
chance just go see the Gabriel movie
let's hope [ __ ] go water yeah so pour
them next week and I'll tell you why man
there's desert it's not who Gabriel is I
love Kevin Hart
I love anybody who has the balls to do
so much I never had the balls to do a
concert film like that put myself on
Brandon Gabriel deserves more anybody
[ __ ] what Gabriel stands for and three
people were sitting on was he stand for
fat people
Mexicans what's he stand for he stands
for a kid that had nothing he stands for
a kid that was a kid amongst men I saw
him standing around men as a kid and
secur'd giggling with [ __ ] braces on
looking around the [ __ ] room and he
became one of the biggest men in that
room and he didn't do it from stealing
you didn't do it from lying he didn't do
it with Twitter he didn't do it with a
YouTube video he did the old-fashioned
way by being 500 pounds and get on a
plane every [ __ ] Wednesday and
staying out there and at the same time
putting food in the mouths of six other
kids that have a [ __ ] dream he put
some of the van he drives them all
around the country whether it's Morty
now for robliz or the guy from San
Antonio or his road manager Ivan you
know he's taking ten kids that had
nothing given my life and I talked to
Joe off-camera yesterday Joe was asking
me and then Joe called me I'm the way
the Holly wouldn't were talking about it
and I said Joe Gabriel stands for that
good comic I don't care what you think
about him I don't care how you feel
about his [ __ ] economy if you don't
like the noises he makes well I like
louis c.k you know I love what I
understand that but if you're a good guy
who had nothing and you work hard and
and if you believe in that you'll go
watch this movie if you believe that
someday something Goods gonna happen to
you by getting up every morning and
working hard what the [ __ ] am I talking
about here
enjoy what do I get up hard at work I
don't know no no you get up and work
hard and believe in yourself
this kid believed himself and like I
said he never [ __ ] did nothing wrong
and the reason why me and Lee in this
room right now is because of Gabriel
aces indirectly so that there it is
there it is in a [ __ ] nutshell not
saying it'll be a funny movie and OB for
me everything else is background music
but this is not you know the one this is
not an acting movie this is not a
[ __ ] this is a movie about a guy who
he sat in this podcast he did me a solid
the way he did me dirty thousand solids
but he didn't just build me a solid he
did this guy's done 300 people solids
more than the other [ __ ] comic I know
and Joe Rogan is a very nice guy and
very generous and gabriel's up there you
know and this is why I'm telling you
guys do me the [ __ ] personal favor
you know I mean what else is coming out
in the 25th there's some no there's one
of them movie coming out I wouldn't go
watch it you know I'm with Gabriel next
[ __ ] Friday I'm gonna fly to Reno and
go right to the movies oh I'm telling
you that Hercules that looks like
garbage you know people the rock people
want to go see that [ __ ] I wouldn't go
see that [ __ ] and I like the rock you
know I got nothing against a rock no I
just don't want to see [ __ ] I like
when the [ __ ] old Italians have
played it oh yeah yeah
Giovanni my Mahoney whatever his [ __ ]
name is yeah Steve Reeves what's the
Superman Hercules for a while probably
yeah the original [ __ ] Superman we
gotta liven this [ __ ] thing up today
where's the music [ __ ] you gotta
hit me with something okay don't tell me
don't know well what should I play you
gotta pick something to light this [ __ ]
up oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] a [ __ ] Green
Day like a [ __ ] that's right
[ __ ] get up what are you scared about
kick this [ __ ]
take this [ __ ] leap kick this
[ __ ]
you walk alone [ __ ]
get up grab your nuts salute the flag
thank you [ __ ] maker for giving you
another day on this [ __ ] rotten apple
what the [ __ ] am I gonna talk about a
lot
what the [ __ ] am I talking about we say
he's supposed to be conducting the whole
that music went off I'm not sure we were
talking about let me give some shoutouts
just straighten out your [ __ ] banter
take it
I want to give a shout-out to my main
man Mike Levin Aaron Waldner Erin Walker
that's his [ __ ] name Shawn Clarke
Danny aki wyatt de mello Kyle Eccleston
Chung Kennedy my main [ __ ] [ __ ]
tipped and Scott [ __ ] black I love
you coccyx all you [ __ ] I love
you all my heart
motley what so what you ain't a [ __ ]
I'm telling you again that infinity
these 500 milligram brownies romantic
Dolores take it to another [ __ ] yeah
they're pretty strong you know I ate all
the goomy's hermanos already how many
they give I know they gave you a bunch a
bunch and they also gave me peanut brew
Oh anybody the peanut brittle make it
down for San Jose I don't smoke so I got
a pop on these things like by nine
o'clock so the parties in my mind it's
going you follow me
I need the oh it's going it's going it's
done where's the music I'm back sure I
thought you were playing it what
happened me you're slipping I'm not the
karate chop the jugular
look at my man Brock Salada is making a
[ __ ] comeback you know Brock's a lot
is no need to one
I just walking figured I run it
in case you got some [ __ ] this [ __ ]
eat the [ __ ] brownie it's a whole new
brownie
that's one [ __ ] you think you're dealing
with some novice in my shop with one gun
over a thousand milligrams before 8 a.m.
what flick let me ask yourself what
would a professional do you wouldn't be
fashionable split the [ __ ] we think we
know apiece
I don't know part of me thinks you might
pardon me thinks you might not I think
we you would do [ __ ] beautiful
another piece so beautiful yourself you
got a blanket you know you sleep on your
stomach you stay warm you little [ __ ]
is up in the air look at the shape issue
so what you gonna do with the white this
weekend where you going to see the white
I'm gonna drive back Saturday and we're
gonna go there's this cool place on
Redondo Beach Pier that you can get like
fresh fish and shrimp and you just tell
them how like by weight how much you
want like a deli counter and then they
cook it for you right on the beach
so it's really cool go do that Saturday
and then Paul's gonna come back with me
that night and then the next day my
cheat for my birthday is uh enchiladas
which I'm pretty excited about come on
yeah but it's uh it was I have to thank
you cuz like I we were talking yesterday
and this is highly in place I like to go
to in Vegas I just said do you and Steve
wanna go and you're like is that really
worth the 800 calories at the gym and I
had to think about it it's not because
of like 1,400 calories and so I'm not
gonna go out but it's just uh you have
to change your whole mindset you know
when you started this process we were
talking about this process for the last
30 days what the Arizona
the more with arizona/tampa me you nari
and we're told that knucklehead the one
night he said well I will read was 52
pounds without even exercise I really
don't know walked outside the way
there's like he's a [ __ ] liar
oh you know and and then and I didn't
like that because listen seventy percent
of it is diet okay
seventy percent over this diet but the
only way when you're losing the weight
for it to really permeate in your mind
is by making you pay for it yeah you
have to pay for half of that weight you
have to make yourself responsible
somewhere whether you walk whether you
run whether you do jumping jacks hey I
love that you're starving yourself and
that's that's gonna work and eventually
I'll work and you'll lose the weight but
you'll put it back on because you can
think you could just do it by that I
rather you keep it off right you know
listen I'm fat right now but say what
you want to say I kept off a hundred
pounds and nobody knows what the [ __ ] I
was eating except me and nobody knows
how much their sacrifice is at the end
of the day I'm a fat [ __ ] just like the
rest of you [ __ ] at all I cut
when I believe do you let me ask you
guys you guys really you know I had a
white shirt on this morning I left the
house with a white shirt on this morning
but as I was leaving for breakfast
instead of eating like usual fat people
oh no no no no I gotta make a protein
shake we have the calories and no
carbohydrates to get my day started so
it kicks open my engine um what now so I
got up this morning I drank some coffee
I drank some water first open my pallet
I fed the cats I drank some coffee
I debated pen you know I [ __ ] around
on the computer I took a shower and I
made the shake and I made the shake and
I was shaking it up and I put the white
t-shirt on and I flipped over boom it
spilled on my [ __ ] shirt now I'll go
home and my wife will have either one
egg scrambled with fruit and a piece of
wheat bread or yeah one egg yolk
two pieces of thin bacon and one piece
of wheat bread and that's my breakfast
you guys want me to lie to you and tell
you that's the breakfast I enjoy if
that's the breakfast I woke up this
morning dreaming about a [ __ ] protein
powder made with water and one egg
scrambled with green peppers in it and
the Greek toast a monkey I'm not saying
I love what my wife makes me anything
but that's what you think I want for
breakfast you [ __ ] crazy
all right you know I want a cheese
omelet I want a steak I want white toast
three pieces six slices
I want a fruit I want potatoes home
fries burnt you know I want just
coca-cola with ice cubes [ __ ] the water
[ __ ] you juice you know that's what I
want that's what I want for lunch oh
please how many first love which lunch
the 11:30 or the one o'clock which lunch
are you referring to because I'm a fat
[ __ ] I'm a real [ __ ] deal fat [ __ ] I
will blast a joint in the quarter to
eleven and by 11:30 and what do you want
to go a little Mexican to tacos some
rice and beans and a couple [ __ ]
enchiladas and a couple cans of coke and
then at one o'clock
I could hook you up again with a Chinese
special from anyway that's just me I'm a
[ __ ] regular day maybe about three we
go for a shake somewhere nice Robin is
the big one who gives a [ __ ] about
little one who's worried about milk and
gluten-free and all that [ __ ] then go
home and see what the wife cooked up I
could eat that two three servings smoked
a joint watch jeopardy and by 8:30 9
o'clock I could be at a sushi place
throwing down with the best one two
three roles couple slices [ __ ] view and
your salad a couple more cans of coke
pick up that diabetes and then I could
go home and turn the TV on and smoke 2
or 3 more [ __ ] bong hits and guess
what I could do at night - at midnight
we put together another ham and cheese
sandwich on toast and mayonnaise a few
chips and another can of coke so you're
talking to the wrong fat [ __ ] yeah
you're talking to the wrong fat [ __ ] I
can run with the best of anybody in the
fat division no you're talking to the
wrong [ __ ] guy can you do something
like that oh my god what would be your
ideal day the truth right here wake up
honey what time do you start inhaling
[ __ ] food see I'm not a huge break
without reason without reefer I'm not
huge guy go with my ideal day give me
the idea of day and I want plate this is
Divine's included this is the milky
way's okay this is the donuts this is
the chip the nachos
give me your ideal day if if I gave you
a million dollars in the bank and you
just didn't give a [ __ ] if you weighed
600 pounds you know what you know maybe
munchies cuz munchies makes it worse
munchies - I want every alright so a bat
Walter I was gonna say a bagel with lox
and cream cheese because it's [ __ ]
amazing but from being bad it would be
going probably them McDonald's
yeah pile of McDonald's getting to Egg
McMuffins and to hash browns because you
put the hash browns in the Egg McMuffin
in it it's amazing yeah I probably at
least one bag of chips or something
maybe between breakfast and lunch at
around 1:00 or something I wouldn't I
wouldn't go crazy and then for lunch I
would love a California burrito which is
just a burrito
but then for french fries it's [ __ ]
amazing and two tacos too small tacos
definitely a couple of sweet things
after that at least two or three and
then dinner a whole Milky Way Ball no no
not a big one I'm I'm thinking about
when I used to work in an office and
they had like small little snacks but
I'll tell you the worst in a second and
then for dinner let's say I order
general got chicken but you have to
order the dumplings with that
well you can't it's like he can't walk
on one leg I ain't mad at you and then
the worst was for like a month or two I
always had that so maybe whenever right
before I died I'm always like it's the
worst I would go to 7-eleven and get two
packs or we see sticks and two gummy
bears and that would probably end the
night that's when I would go crazy with
the Swedes waiting oh and all day I cook
the other day oh no not a sip of water
no no sweet coke no no it's not for the
calories or anything I just I liked the
taste better how many dinners we G
usually one but I'd [ __ ] I've had the
days where 11 o'clock you go make some
peanut butter and jelly sandwiches and
I've been single so it was it wasn't
like a anyone was gonna see I would hit
must be harder with Terry what's that
like I I feel a little bit
self-conscious if I was like what if I
like if Paul was there and like at
midnight I was gonna make a sandwich I
would think twice about it I didn't give
a [ __ ] yeah about Heather I've never had
multiple like full dinners but it's
always like peanut butter no salt will
Dennis I think he had a couple different
people's houses like I can try the beach
boy I'm sure I could have done better
yeah I could do it every day breakfast
is and I'm not but the whole time I
didn't talk about cakes I'm not a cake
guy yeah I'll eat a doughnut from yum
Yum's
once a month you know a good chocolate
coconut doughnut once a month I love
pumpkin pie but I don't need it all the
time you know I was always a beggar's I
was always choosy with my diet okay so I
know if I do one thing I can't do them
all I know that the thing that kills me
the worst is sure sure that kills me the
worst at this age right now okay I think
I do it sugar
definitely tacks on it's not going
anywhere if I eat a whole chicken that
goes away okay I could eat one little
piece of candy and it sticks around like
[ __ ]
be selfish under me it's [ __ ] crazy
when you watching this [ __ ] and took a
look at this [ __ ] and it's great I mean
I think the point of that was just like
what you look at now and you have to
keep your portion down yeah and it would
be great to go to the strombel it's like
for me that it'd be great but it's like
I'm not gonna spend 10 hours in the gym
3 hours in the gym it's not worth it it
doesn't taste that good but I think
that's what they people mean when they
say nothing tastes as good as being
skinny feels I think that's [ __ ] I
think nothing cases as good to make you
work out
being skinny is overrated yeah I mean
you know food is [ __ ] tremendous yeah
when you when you sit and you with your
family in you especially if you're an
ethnic family and I'm about everybody
[ __ ] like the you know everybody
likes to [ __ ] eat and and like I told
Leo yesterday I think was one of my
lifestyles you know I didn't know about
lifestyle changes fight went away
watches Rick Ramos that's when I found
out about what a lifestyle change was
what you have to do differently and I'm
not angry I needed to do this you know I
knew when I left these coasts that there
was a bunch of foods I was never gonna
eat again I knew it because I'm so
hard-headed and so old-school that I'm
so old school that I knew I would never
eat them again like I'm like anybody
else I love eating late-night we all
love eating curry in the [ __ ] morning
after a bar but I won't do it here you
know that in a couple of years you know
only one night got sick but at the other
part where would you go we wouldn't go
to Denny's that night there ain't
nowhere to go this isn't like I'm in Los
Angeles and the valley I'm telling you
people beside Denny's where are we gonna
go to eat anywhere else we're now I
guess in-n-out burger what times I'm out
still you know I don't want either [ __ ]
I don't go to those [ __ ] diners and
having the cheeseburger deluxe
[ __ ] you sleep like a [ __ ] baby
afterward
am I gonna go to Denny's someone that
was murdered burgers you go home go to
sleep and two hours later you're waking
up you can't [ __ ] sleep you're
[ __ ] your Pole a bowl will do that
to a woman there's no [ __ ] going to
bed and getting up in the middle of
night with a stomachache and you're
[ __ ] and you're cursing god you're
puking and you're [ __ ] in your [ __ ]
on fire now you've been [ __ ] for 45
minutes who's gonna go back to sleep
you're in shock your [ __ ] been
sitting there [ __ ] in shock at 3:00
in the morning you just sit on the couch
watching [ __ ] the news with your feet
up in the air with a robe on freezing
and you're like I'll never go to
Chipotle again little [ __ ] too late
you just lost the day's work you're
sitting there like a Mook you know
you're [ __ ] dehydrated cuz all the
fluid came onto your [ __ ] with that
stroke bowl the same company along the
McDonald's they outline around the
corner meanwhile you're self-conscious
and you're [ __ ] taking care yourself
go [ __ ] yourself you dumb [ __ ]
you want to take care yourself go to
Hana calm that's how you [ __ ] take
care yourself it's not a [ __ ]
supplement it's an optimization program
it brings out the best in you they start
with the hemp force protein they start
with the alpha brain those are their
[ __ ] catalysts alpha brain is what
makes [ __ ] alpha alpha alpha brain is
what makes on it tick you understand me
what's in it what the [ __ ] do I know I
look like a scientist to you do I got a
white robe on all I know is you have
good dreams it makes you focus more you
become more alert to your [ __ ]
surroundings
bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla try
it if you don't like it you get your
money back and you have to send the rest
of their product back one time you could
pull that [ __ ] scam don't think you
pull it back every other [ __ ] week
you're buying you get your [ __ ] money
back so loosen up [ __ ] number two
they also have kettlebells and ropes and
anything to make you a better human
being all around is it gonna help you
with your character you're gonna stop
shoplifting some [ __ ] Walmart no you
still gonna be a nasty piece of [ __ ] but
you'll be in bed the best best shape of
your life your mind will be thinking
[ __ ] clearly and that's what you
from yourself go to Hana calm right now
go to the box and press in Turks Church
CH you are CH get 10% off your order
plus they put your mailing list you get
other discount some of the crazy stuff
look into on it on it before you go to
GNC under these other companies look
into on it they got the best of the best
in their products I wouldn't [ __ ] lie
to you I I [ __ ] swear by him
I live by him I go to jiu-jitsu at 12:30
I popped to shroom Texas at 11 o'clock
that's how I roll [ __ ] I go on
the alpha brain 30 days on 30 days off
when I'm riding when I'm performing at a
heavy tour schedule
I suggest the same to you go to on it
see what they got available to you they
also have to stay on a program like
Dollar Shave Club where they mail it
right to your [ __ ] house monthly not
to leave the house number two if you
guys didn't know this if you live in a
coma or if you're [ __ ] dead I was in
the front companion last night I went up
there first thing I did was go on the
kitchen and I started devouring the
spicy pistachios they have these new
kernel corn something nature's box calm
has the best snacks on the [ __ ]
market you understand me those habanero
maple pretzels will [ __ ] put you in a
different dimension naturebox
nutritionist approved it's a snack you
have to get up number one go to the
[ __ ] bar
into the thing in your office put a
dollar into the machine [ __ ] that noise
what you're gonna do is go to nature's
box calm select what snacks you'd like
to have open up a couple bar you know
change it up for different than one
thing get the cocoa covered almonds
which I love get the chili lined
pistachios or the pepper pistachio get
the black and white granola get the the
habanero pretzels guys anything that
they have is good for you great
ingredients nutritionists approve you
put them in your desk in there you can
eat them you want to mix them up a
little piece of fruit they are delicious
if you order nature's box com2us the
first time the first time you get 50%
off your order so you might as well [ __ ]
him and he has really
they're gonna be time and get a bunch of
stuff you get 50% off and after that
read whatever the [ __ ] they do anyway
calling nature's box calm what type of
snacks they got I swear to god I'm a fat
[ __ ] these snacks do not disappoint you
understand me
they do not disappoint try those
habanero maple [ __ ] pretzel things
they are delicious go to nature box
common press in Joey Joey Jo ey you're
50% off 50% off [ __ ] from your
first daughter you understand number two
last weekend I had the pleasure last
Thursday night I'm hanging out with the
Navy wife guys my man Peter and Dave and
I gotta tell you something they are the
most pleasant guys in the world I did a
couple of dabs at them told me I got
[ __ ] up I wanted to have a great show
they gave me some of the gummi bears I
have some of their favorite pens at the
house there's another one I use here
like the service baby pen in the market
golden elder life.com
see what they got to offer you I know
you don't love the baby pen if you
mentioned me you get 20% off your first
order get to know that this is this is
the number one wax [ __ ] vape pen out
there I am messing with wax and oil wax
and oil wax and oil I'm sorry thank you
the other one wax and oil so go to now
live.com see what they got to offer you
get it sent right to your house and you
get ready smoked oil whatever the [ __ ]
you want to smoke bazooka juice stop
make your powders whatever [ __ ] you tell
me something good you want another piece
of brownie nothing why are you good
about leaving your home dialing what the
[ __ ] you want to talk about a kick to
the head about oh my god
drinking water I'm getting ready for
tomorrow I medicalized Vegas you know
Lee's been pushing it all week hey get
this Cali Vegas I'm not that big of a
Vegas guy I know I do really good shows
they have a great time in Vegas Lee's
come and Steve Simone's opening for me
I know that I'm Lee welcome I heard that
the South Point has to get great seafood
not a buffet but seafood restaurant and
I'm very excited being I'm a junkie
tomorrow I'm also gonna be on some
[ __ ] News Channel at 11:30 in the
morning then I'm gonna hang out I'm
gonna see my main man Mario arias you
know how long I know Mario arias for how
long sixth grade yeah he's gonna have
some tremendous stories for you tomorrow
Oh is he the basketball coach no he's a
kid though it's just accounting a sixth
grade with my skin from the class and
sing songs and we all got plain quote
playing hooky he got caught in one
division with he used to play hooky with
two girls he was another guy in two
broad they were both [ __ ] I'm in the
sixth grade they were both playing hooky
at this girl's house and they were both
[ __ ] two girls they'd go home with a
pay a woman would [ __ ] him on one bed
right in front of each other in the six
very nice neighborhood huh
Jesus Christ don't [ __ ] around in North
Bergen now they're white trash where the
[ __ ] they are I know some people do not
they're gonna listen to this coming Joey
how can you call this white dress I'm
not saying it was all white trash but
there's a big big [ __ ] number you
guys are white trash that's a shame if
you guys see I even have my North Bergen
shirt on I ripped that [ __ ] it
was just a mentality the mentality of
you already have a predetermined job at
a time you're a team it was them Italian
by the time you were 35 you already have
an idea what you're gonna do those guys
don't change that's what that's what my
story was I never wanted an income
ceiling I know that some is I wasn't
made 10,000 but I also wanted the option
to make 30 million if I had if this
situation ever arose you know I never
wanted to be at the same place at the
same time every day of my life that was
a decision I [ __ ] made you know I
think I got a job in an office I would
have probably been running an office
today was no telemarketing off is a
sports betting office it don't [ __ ]
matter I would have still been [ __ ]
running an office today these are the
things I could have done I just wanted
something different out of my life
if I want every day to be different
sales is one way of doing that you know
but I still had to go to the same
[ __ ] spot every day you know so I'm
very fortunate that I got to do what I
love you know and I like come upon it
you just keep [ __ ] swinging you keep
trying you don't settle you don't settle
you know we went to school for
everything he was up here whether you
like it and you could do it for a job do
you think you'd be doing that 35 I don't
see home not know you you would do it
for money yeah
not because you don't love it no no you
don't love it or you couldn't you can't
wait to get out that's why I could I
like it's kind of like what you were
saying I I got really I really didn't
like the the system that was going on
how they treated people and then being
someone for 70 or 80 hours a week and
you're only helping someone else like
you're not really helping herself I
didn't feel like I was doing any like I
wouldn't get any credit for a show if it
was good or bad so why not try to make
the money for myself you know it's
amazing that I've been scared a lot but
that was them one of the times I was
scared the most one I knew that I had to
get a job man I knew that uh you have to
get a job you know and that's a lot of
people I get it I get it that's why no
life isn't you have to get a job you
know people always send me emails all
Joey I really want to do comi I really
want to join the band but I get it but
you got to get a job you can't just get
in a band and hope your dream takes you
that you're gonna have a window you're
gonna have a three year that you gotta
make a [ __ ] living so what are you
gonna do yeah you might have a
girlfriend that helps you out for now
that's not gonna last that girl's gonna
come home one day and wake up and go
this guy's a [ __ ] loser
he's on my couch I'm Bay he works ten
hours a week he's complaining he dresses
up like these [ __ ] Richie Sambora but
meanwhile he's a [ __ ] Mook you know
see God do something so you got to get a
[ __ ] job
it's not fair but you got to [ __ ]
work right I mean I didn't know I could
either I did both I was a criminal
part-time and then when I didn't want to
be a criminal for a couple weeks I do I
get a [ __ ] job for a few weeks were
you laughing about Lee I'm not laughing
look at the shape you Liao stone the you
right now I can see through your eyes
that I interrupted
oh yeah my mode up oh yeah and they're
not red I'm not talking about that your
eyes are closed no they're not even
close
oh you're just zoning out on me you're
like Jim Miller right now I could just
look at this [ __ ] all those terrible
anyway I hope you enjoyed the podcast
today I hope it's not gonna happen again
other Thursday we just I never want to
double up on podcast and shove this [ __ ]
down your [ __ ] throat this is
something for you to watch as an
entertainment level what do you think
Lee tell me something good cop said you
didn't talk today is a much you showed
up here like Henry Hill when you came
over that old lady's house to eat with
Joe Pesci's mother you don't say much
you don't need much you don't [ __ ] do
much you sure I can't offer you another
brownie yeah I feel like you're not even
love I feel like you didn't get enough I
cheated you know I feel I feel pretty
good but tomorrow brownie I have you
could what are you gonna do the rest of
the day tell me about you Dana now I
gotta go home and do what eat something
and then pass out and then I'm gonna go
work out and then I have Rick Ramos
today how many times you workout this
week
how are you been you don't give a [ __ ]
you don't think any days off my I took
we took sunday off Sunday yeah we took
good that we were gonna run out to
dinner but I you know I take sunday off
this weekend too but surprise six days a
week
[ __ ] eat your [ __ ] your [ __ ] your
body's a freak look at you about Warren
no I could read the [ __ ] thing oh I
love you [ __ ]
we'll be back Monday and next Wednesday
same bat-time same bat-channel Wednesday
was an in-house studio I love you
[ __ ] with all my heart I want to
thank on it
I want to thank Dollar Shave Club I want
to thank nature's box.com I want to
thank Hulu Plus
I want to thank nail their life I want
to take a skate park
comp the helping us put this up together
and to come to you guys alright and now
that the show should Ishould this case
pumped up oh yeah no the show's over
remember go to naturebox calm and or a
great-tasting healthy snacks at 50%